welcome to this video I called Leah
corner one of the most frequent
opponents 11 out of 14 and not so bad
but maybe I can help him with the score
by playing an opening I have no idea
about the growing fat lady yeah no idea
is a bit harsh but it's really not much
more than that game this line yup I
never really thought that this is so
this is some dangerous some very it's
very comparable to the Queen sir to some
Queens gambit lines like has got the
bishop pair here very early on and
shouldn't have any any real problems
there so what am I going to do I can
even go for this typical be five block
but it's not necessary i can also go ad
ideas before and then be five i can also
do this it's also very very ok for black
be 5c five
yeah on be4 i go see five and i'm happy
Bishop on g7 is not doing such a bad job
it looks at this d4 pawn which is
protected so usually you would say okay
that's not a good bishop it isn't
brilliant but it at least is sitting on
this diagonal we're after be 5c five it
can do something and be five is about
the only idea that right has I mean you
can of course even try to improve pieces
at night and 0 e 1 d 3 c 5 yeah it took
say if it takes ages though so I don't
know the sugar 5linx good anyway so
let's do it b5 again the c5 coming I am
maybe he's angling for some Luke a five
not quite sure well I mean what position
is ok but I don't really see him um I
don't see anything anything great it was
my idea regrouping here to attack the
befall upon and he just trade stuff yeah
but I don't I don't think it's it's it's
dangerous really I can even play Queen
before this is this is a good move by
the way let's do it activate the Queen
you have to take first yeah now the this
minority attack and that he played for
his is completed but what exactly is it
is this is Pawn week I don't think so he
has very little ideas to attack it ok so
Pepsi two is going 95 Bishop c295 takes
takes Knight c7 I Scott 94 that I have
to that I have to take into account ok
maybe I should really go i have 6 cm you
know maybe let's do that so that 95 is
not happening
hmm yeah I don't know is this about
equal maybe it is night down I a sea
angling for Bishop d3 maybe maybe he's
doing this okay let's cover g6 so that
after Bishop d3 I can move the bishop
you so let's go back
and maybe Bishop g4 was an idea actually
now it's not a big deal
yeah it's probably still equal I really
cannot do very much I'm okay with the
bishop and everything but it's difficult
to really do do something substantial as
the position is so symmetrical and night
for check GTX Bishop takes Knight you
might stumble into some awkward pin
there I wonder said at an idea I don't
know I don't know maybe neither for was
interesting but I'm just going for
normal moves
okay the so c5 is that said something I
know I don't know a time morning can I
go D for threatening g4 okay I cannot
calculate it so quickly so going to
gamble a little bit hope it works efore
95 is the critical line I think
I can maybe Bishop c5 actually oh I
didn't expect this more let's take it
there should be six I even have e to e
to intermediate move and e2 how is he
defending against this
quite resigned yes he isn't I guess he
isn't now yes to Kiev to deform he has
to play I thought he has to go your form
and trying to hold this position which
is probably going to work I can still of
course triumph with my bishop and so on
but it's nothing nothing too great so
let's have a look at the whole the whole
thing got the Greenfeld yeah this is a
very young gasps comline one of the more
strategic flights that white can play
against the groom fault the the problem
with it is it is just not doing much in
terms of putting pressure on black with
those simple moves play get some has
already equalized here ok 2 p.m. and and
here I'm already I think quite
comfortable I don't really see much
happening any b5 like go see 5 as
mentioned and that's happened in the
game no I didn't end up like that but
yeah it's probably it still should
probably be equal but it's easier for
black because I know how I'm winning out
with the bishop pair and whatever and
why it just has to just basically
sitting around ok but we got all those
trades that he went b5 yep I had to take
it yeah this was very embarrassing so
here yeah and this is of course a
position that should end in a draw it is
so um um yeah almost symmetrical I'd say
I probably will place he five at one
point and he takes put something on T
for it should be a draw
now be shuffled a little bit and it
wasn't really helping him what you did
but I think it still should be ok here
this was a jesting move I wasn't sure
about it though this this and it wide no
tags I thought here could be interesting
this pin is awkward but I wasn't really
sure like this I can go here and after
here check and we even go to f5 and it's
not convincing anyway so Bishop 86 is
good and now here yeah I know c5 Sean's
it irritating him he takes before I yeah
and now the engine gives this move as
leading to equality interestingly enough
ok I don't I cannot really keep the
tension I guess hmm yeah oops sorry so
ok I can always just end the game by by
doing this kind of simplification which
is just a complete draw Jo here yet to
take with the pawn and defend this
position which is not fun but it's still
yeah what's probably should still draw
with just two points per player I don't
think black should be able to win ok
thanks for watching